il y a quelques mois je vous fais une
vidéo pour savoir quel smartphone
Samsung acheter en 2022 là on va se
faire une petite mise à jour pour savoir
quel smartphone Samsung a acheté fin
2022 voir tout début 2023 parce que
début 2023 vont arriver les nouveaux
Samsung Galaxy S23 fatalement donc bon
ça sera un peu moins d'actualité on en
fera encore une autre année prochaine
histoire de se mettre à jour mais là ça
me paraît super important de regarder
par rapport au produit qui sont sortis
cette année il y en a quand même pas mal
et il y en a qui sont sortis et il y en
a que j'attendais qui ne sont jamais
sortis on va donc regarder quels sont
les smartphones Samsung à acheter fin
2022 lesquels sont intéressants il y a
eu beaucoup de changements au niveau des
prix il y a eu des sorties qui sont très
fortes vous allez voir c'est super
intéressant allez go
[Musique]
c'est aujourd'hui une vidéo qui est
réalisée en partenariat avec l'école aux
cloque si vous rêvez de devenir
développeur web je vous invite vraiment
à venir écouter ce qui suit l'école au
club dispense une formation de six mois
en téléprésentiel le téléprésentiel
c'est quoi ils l'ont écrit ici c'est
l'accompagnement humain allié au confort
de l'apprentissage à la maison et en
chaussons en gros vous vous connectez
dès le matin à 9h à vos cours vous avez
une salle de classe une vraie salle de
classe avec un professeur tous les
élèves sont connectés en visio vous êtes
là vous êtes en pantoufle avec votre
petit café chez vous vous êtes bien et
vous allez apprendre les métiers du code
dispensés par des professionnels vous
assisterez donc à des cours en direct
vous allez travailler en solo en équipe
avec plein d'outils différents vous
utiliserez notamment cela qui est
discord pour venir vous connecter pour
échanger notamment avec les autres
élèves ici les maîtres mots c'est
dialogues échangent entre aide ça vous
permettra notamment de gagner en
autonomie pendant six mois vous allez
vous connecter tous les jours apprendre
travailler pour la fin avoir une
formation certifiée par ministère du
Travail à un niveau bac + 2 alors
rassurez-vous vous serez encadré en
permanence par une équipe pédagogique
c'est une méthode qui est basée
entièrement sur les rapports humains
alors pour vous inscrire c'est très
facile déjà je vous mets un lien en bas
dans la description vous avez besoin
d'un ordinateur c'est la base on parle
de faire du code ici deuxièmement d'une
connexion Internet et troisièmement dans
réveil forcément il faut bien se lever
un moment ou un autre c'est une
formation de six mois destination des
débutants pour devenir développeur web
une fois de plus je vous mets le lien en
bas dans la description et merci à
l'école oklock d'avoir sponsorisé cette
vidéo alors pour vous faire cette vidéo
on a besoin de plusieurs trucs on a
besoin de crayon on a besoin de deux
papiers et puis j'ai besoin d'un
ordinateur pour venir vous montrer des
choses parce qu'il faut vraiment venir
regarder hyper en détail alors la
première chose à venir se mettre dans la
tête et pour se remettre un peu dans le
truc c'est que vous posez la question
quand vous voulez acheter un smartphone
de plusieurs choses la première chose
c'est votre budget fatalement le budget
vous pouvez venir y allouer et puis
après surtout vos usages il y a
plusieurs usages très fort à venir voir
premier usage ça va être tout ce qui va
être photo et vidéo je le mets un peu
ensemble c'est pour les créatifs ceux
qui ont envie de venir faire du Tik Tok
company partager des choses avoir des
souvenirs ça c'est le premier point le
deuxième point ça va être tout ce qui va
être divertissement divertissement
j'entends tout ce qui va être série film
même écoute de musique même si tous les
smart pour la musique sont quand même
très très bons Netflix mycanal j'en
passe et des meilleurs l'autre point ça
va être un peu du divertissement mais
c'est encore un peu différent c'est
toute la partie gaming parce que autant
le divertissement là sur votre écran et
bien vous allez avoir des différences
entre du Super AMOLED ou du LCD bon ok
ça va changer un peu mais en terme de
gaming il y a des jeux qui me
demanderont plus de performance donc il
y a certains smartphones qui vous
permettront pas d'atteindre de la
performance la question de l'autonomie
elle est à peu près partout mais j'irai
voilà les usages principaux et puis un
autre usage qui va être un peu différent
un peu plus niché ça va être toute la
question de la productivité hop la
productivité la question de la
productivité elle va être la plus si
vous êtes un professionnel si vous avez
besoin d'un stylet si vous avez besoin
de prendre des notes et si et ça après
ce sont des usages mixtes la
productivité c'est plus les au taf les
photos on en fait à peu près tous le
divertissement à peu près tout le monde
le gaming pas tout le monde ou alors ça
dépend donc voilà un peu ces différents
éléments clés une fois qu'on a son usage
qu'on s'est un peu où on veut aller on
va s'orienter vers une gamme en
particulier on va resituer très
rapidement les gammes de Samsung pour
savoir de quoi on parle il y a
différentes gammes chez Samsung toutes
les gammes s'appelle Galaxy quelque
chose ça c'est Samsung vous allez avoir
en face la gamme Z qui va être le
pliable dans un sens ou dans l'autre
vous avez le Z fold vous avez le Z flip
on regarde dans quelques instants vous
avez ensuite la gamme S la gamme S et la
gamme photo c'est la gamme vidéo avec
aussi de la productivité on va regarder
ça vous avez ensuite la gamme a la gamme
a c'est plutôt le milieu de gamme qui va
être plutôt sympa au niveau de la photo
on peut faire du gaming mais ça dépend
aussi des produits puis vous avez la
gamme M vous avez beaucoup moins de
référence ce qu'il faut venir connaître
ici ce qu'il faut venir savoir ce qui
est super important c'est que dans ces
gammes regardez hop là je vais changer
de stylo la gamme Z c'est la gamme de
l'innovation vous allez avoir deux
smartphones le plus important le plus
beau celui que je vous recommande et qui
me plaît énormément c'est le flip le
flip vous savez c'est le smartphone qui
vient se plier où on vient réduire
l'encombrement je vous les présenter
alors il y avait eu le zflip 3 l'année
dernière qui était hyper canon le zflip
4 qui vient d'être annoncé qui est sorti
et qui est aussi génial qu'une belle
mise à jour la grosse différence que
vous allez avoir attention ici truc qui
est important c'est le tarif le prix le
prix le prix je sais pas si vous le
savez mais c'est Samsung au bout de
quelques semaines quelques on va dire
les tarifs baisse vraiment fortement ce
qui fait que autant à Netflix 4 tout de
suite reste quand même assez élevé on
est à 1109 euros ce qui est quand même
un beau budget mais le Z flip 4 elle zip
3 ont effectivement des différences
d'ailleurs je vous renvoie ma vidéo du
zip 4 comme ça vous saurez tout mais
pour autant le Netflix 3 reste vraiment
d'actualité est un très bon smartphone
donc je vous invite à venir jeter un
petit coup d'oeil à les fouiner sur le
net à droite à gauche parce que j'ai
réussi à trouver 730 euros et je trouve
qu'à 730 euros vous avez un super
rapport qualité-prix vous avez un très
joli produit vous avez une superbe
innovation et c'est hyper hyper hyper
hyper canon ça reste quand même beaucoup
d'argent il faut pouvoir les mettre mais
si vous voulez un flip et que vous
n'avez pas plus de 1000 euros à mettre
dans un zip 4 et bien vous pouvez aller
sur un Z Flick 3 qui reste une fois de
plus très cool et qui a toutes les mises
à jour logicielles qu'on retrouve sur un
type 4 donc bon on peut y aller ensuite
vous allez avoir un deuxième produit
dans la famille Z c'est le fold alors le
fold je vous l'avais déjà expliqué aussi
je l'avais déjà montré lumière comment
ça s'éteindre en fait le folle vous
augmentez vous avez une petite tablette
vous augmentez la surface utile donc bon
c'est pas mal c'est intéressant c'est
beaucoup plus niché productivité on a
1700 euros le Smart attention c'est
vraiment pas fait pour tout le monde je
vous conseille de prendre le s-pn pour
le fold edition que vous avez avec pour
venir prendre des notes griffonner c'est
ça une fois de plus je vous renvoie mon
test de ce smartphone parce que vous
allez voir il est vraiment assez complet
on comprend vraiment le fonctionnement
de ce smartphone s'il est fait pour vous
pour moi il est vraiment pas fait pour
tout le monde si vous voulez un
smartphone comme ça vous n'avez pas
besoin d'aller voir cette vidéo parce
que vous savez déjà ce qu'il en est vous
l'aurez déjà acheté ou pas si vous avez
pas les moyens ou pas si il est trop
cher mais en tout cas vous aurez déjà eu
cette démarche là donc bon le folle
c'est le smartphone un peu nicher c'est
un peu différent ensuite vous avez la
gamme S alors la gamme S c'est la gamme
photo vidéo et un peu productivité on va
regarder ça on a eu cette année le S22
on a eu le S22+ et on a eu le S22 ultra
les S22 et S22+ sont très proches
différents de diagonales d'écran un peu
plus grand si bon ok c'est le modèle
plus on comprendra le S22 ultra c'est un
smartphone qui est très différent qui
est la plus pour de la productivité vous
allez avoir un stylet avec également qui
est un peu une évolution de la gamme
note qui a disparu chez Samsung si vous
voulez un smartphone performant si vous
voulez aller loin sur du gaming si vous
voulez ce qu'il y a aujourd'hui en terme
de divertissement surtout de photos et
de vidéos de jours comme de nuit on est
sur la gamme S si vous n'avez pas besoin
de productivité vous n'allez pas sur le
ultra vous allez sur le plus le S22 et
le S22+ sont de très bons smartphones et
surtout les tarifs ont vraiment baisser
sur le site de Samsung je vous le donne
d'ailleurs je vous mets tous les liens
en bas dans la description les jeter un
coup d’œil le S22 il coûtait 859 €, il
est à 699 €, ça reste de l'argent dans
les moins de 700 balles sur le
smartphone et c'est vraiment vraiment
très très bien le S22 plus coûtait 1059
euros et là on peut le trouver à 899
euros autant vous dire que je trouve
c'est un tarif qui est extrêmement canon
le S22 ultra reste quand même cher on
est au-dessus de 1000 euros écoutez 1259
euros et là on est à 1049 euros pour moi
la vraie bonne affaire aujourd'hui si
vous n'avez pas de smartphone de Samsung
vous voulez aller sur une gamme S ce que
vous aurez mieux en termes de photos de
performance Super Écran taux de
rafraîchissement après un truc qui
déchire le S22 ici je vous le recommande
plus plus plus je vous le dis à 699 €
sur le site de Samsung vous allez pas
vous planter donc vous pouvez y aller
franchement les yeux fermés alors maman
je tourne cette vidéo il y a les French
days ça dure pas bien longtemps mais
normalement si vous regardez tout de
suite cette vidéo vous pouvez y aller
vous allez avoir plus des offres et
c'est vraiment hyper canon donc je vous
invite une fois de plus à passer par le
lien en bas dans la description tout en
sachant qu'après il y aura le plus tard
le Black Friday qui arrivera enfin bref
vous connaissent un peu les promos qu'on
a à la fin de l'année donc ça c'est très
très cool et c'est vraiment pour moi la
très très bonne affaire une fois de plus
pour tout savoir tous les détails de ce
smartphone je vous renvoie à montage de
ce smartphone mais je vous dis à moins
de 700 €, on a ici un truc qui est
vraiment génial alors il y a un autre
produit qui est sorti également dans la
gamme S c'est le
s21f cette année tout de suite au moment
où je fais la vidéo on n'a pas encore eu
de S22 fe je pensais qu'il allait
arriver à la rentrée mais a priori il y
en a pas je ne sais pas si Samsung va en
sortir un à la fin de l'année donc pour
l'instant on va vraiment se parler du
S21 et feu qui reste très canon et en
termes de tarifs coûté 759 € et on le
retrouve tout de suite à 599 € 599 €
pour une bête comme ça on est dans la
gamme S c'est vraiment un excellent
rapport qualité prix et je vous le dis
le S22 ici il est à 699 €. donc très
honnêtement de vous à moi si vous pouvez
rajouter 100 euros de plus je vous
recommande énormément de passer sur le
S22 au lieu d'aller sur le S21 et 600
euros c'est beaucoup ça reste beaucoup
d'argent et je le sais si c'est
compliqué vous allez sur le S21 et feu
qui est aussi un excellent smartphone et
qui a tous les atouts qu'on attend d'un
smartphone haut de gamme sur la photo
vidéo le divertissement le gaming on a
la performance bref une super bête là
vous pouvez y aller facilement ensuite
on va se diriger vers la gamme alors la
gamme mâle est beaucoup plus large vous
avez beaucoup plus de produits mais
cette gamme a elle est cool alors ce qui
est très surprenant regardez je vais
vous le montrer directement sur mon
ordinateur c'est qu'en fait je vous le
disais dans ma vidéo que j'ai fait au
mois de mars je m'attendais à voir
arriver un Samsung Galaxy à 73 cette
année ici il a été annoncé il est
officiel il existe mais il n'est pas là
on ne le retrouve pas chez Samsung vous
avez un a535g vous avez le a52s l'année
dernière 5G ok le A33 vous avez le à 23
le A13 le après 5G 4G vous avez le a04s
le A03 l'année dernière à 0,3s de
l'année dernière également vous voyez
mais il y a pas le à 73 donc je pense
que la stratégie de Samsung ici c'était
de se dire le a73 il va être trop proche
du a535g et le a53 c'est le smartphone
que Samsung veut bosser à fond et qui le
smartphone qu'ils aiment le plus parce
que dans lequel il croit plus j'y crois
moi aussi énormément je trouve très bien
c'est un excellent rapport qualité prix
mais et si on regarde et qu'on voyage de
l'autre côté de la Méditerranée et qu'on
voit au Maroc on va chez Samsung Maroc
Samsung Africa vous voyez en haut là et
bien il existe il y est il est
disponible donc si vous êtes en Afrique
du Nord vous pouvez acheter votre as 73
5G mais ici en France en tout cas on ne
l'a pas donc je trouve ça assez marrant
c'est surprenant alors pour autant le
a535g est un smartphone qui est hyper
canon j'ai testé je vous invite une fois
de plus à venir voir ma vidéo et vous
voyez normalement écoutez 459 euros là
on le trouve à 399 euros et je trouve
que ce tarif là il est hyper canon alors
ça reste de l'argent bien évidemment on
est d'accord mais si vous voulez c'est
un super compromis parce que vous avez
une dalle Super AMOLED parce que vous
avez un capteur qui va être très
performant en termes de photos sur votre
grand-angle ultra grand-angle ça sera un
peu moins bon fatalement parce que si on
veut monter en qualité sur l'ultra grand
angle il faut aller sur la gamme S bien
évidemment on comprendra on a quand même
suffisamment de performances pour venir
jouer à des jeux même des jeux qui sont
très exigeants donc pas de souci comme
on est sur du Super AMOLED tous les
pixels noirs sont les pixels éteint on a
donc une vraie profondeur au niveau de
l'image c'est très beau une super
qualité donc c'est un smartphone qui est
extrêmement polyvalent et je vous dis à
un peu moins de 400 euros 399 euros on
peut pas se planter ici sur le Samsung
Galaxy
a535g après vous en avez d'autres des
smartphones et je vous le disais dans la
gamme le a52s 5G bon ok pour moi c'est
aujourd'hui le truc qui est un peu moins
bon le à 33 je trouve très couche je
pense que jusqu'à 33 on peut pas se
planter forcément on aura des capteurs
qui sont un peu moins bon on dirait un
peu moins loin au niveau de la photo
mais on est quand même sur une dalle
Super AMOLED on a quand même un capteur
grand temps qui est de bonne qualité on
a aussi une belle autonomie avec une
bonne batterie ça reste quelque chose
qui fonctionne vraiment très très bien
après on va descendre un peu on va dire
en qualité mais on aura un petit peu
moins parce que les smartphones vont
coûter aussi moins cher sur le à 23 le
A13 pour moi aujourd'hui ce qui est
vraiment hyper important le smartphone
qui est hyper canon aujourd'hui pour moi
le a53 hop là je sais plus écrire c'est
le smartphone sur lequel vous vous
planterez pas c'est un excellent rapport
qualité prix une fois de plus et puis
vous avez la gamme M alors la gamme M
c'est pareil on va venir voir ici
regardez mobilité smartphone Galaxy m
Galaxy m vous avez pas énormément de
référence vous allez avoir le m235 j'ai
le M33 le M32 on passe à la génération
de l'année dernière vérifie le M13 alors
on voit effectivement il y en a un peu
pour tous les budgets et ça c'est plutôt
très très bien le M33 je le trouve cool
c'est un bon smartphone je vous l'avais
déjà dit dans ma vidéo du mois de mars
mais il coûte 329 euros et quand on voit
aujourd'hui que le a53 est bien un peu
plus cher mais pas grand chose je vous
recommande d'aller sur le a53 vraiment
en cette fin d'année donc si on
récapitule les smartphones qu'il faut
venir aujourd'hui en cette fin d'année
acheter chez Samsung et bien on va avoir
le zflip 3 parce que en termes de
positionnement tarifaire il est hyper
canon je dis pas que les étiquettes
n'est pas bien j'adore les éthique 4
mais le zip 3 il est quand même beaucoup
moins cher et ça vaut vraiment le coup
d'aller dessus donc le zip 3 c'est
vraiment un truc que je vous recommande
vous pouvez venir trouver une fois de
plus pourquoi pas en occasion ou même
sur du neuf a beaucoup moins cher je
vous recommande également le S22 qui a
baissé en tarif qui est hyper canon même
si le S21 est feu est très cool je vous
dis à 100 euros d'écart ça vaut le coup
de monter sur le S22 une fois de plus je
ne sais pas si un s22fe va sortir dans
l'intervalle et il sera peut-être
intéressant j'en sais rien donc je peux
pas bien me positionner dessus mais la
très très bonne nouvelle c'est que le
S22 est très cool je vous recommande
énormément le a53 qui est pour moi super
smartphone qui a tout de ce qu'il y a de
mieux dans la gamme a même si on n'a pas
de A65 ça reste quand même bizarre mais
c'est comme ça et puis surtout voilà
voilà alors après il faut y aller en
fonction de son budget il faut faire ce
qu'on peut il faut pas se mettre en
difficulté par rapport à un smartphone
le A33 qui doit un peu moins que à 53
c'est aussi un peu moins cher fatalement
et bien vous pouvez y aller aussi c'est
un très très bon smartphone mais voilà
ma sélection c'est le zflip 3 c'est le
S22 c'est le a53 sont vraiment mes coups
de cœur ce que je vous recommande après
les autres sont bons mais voilà il
fallait forcément opérer des choix donc
dites-moi vous ce que vous en pensez
quel smartphone de Samsung pourrait vous
tenter sur cette fin d'année marquez-le
moi juste en bas bien évidemment dans
les commentaires et puis si vous avez
des questions n'hésitez pas à y aller
également et que nous on se retrouve
très vite pour continuer à parler tech
ça vous le savez je vous retrouve
également sur Tik Tok il y a les reals
sur Instagram il y a les YouTube shorts
également ici donc voilà et puis surtout
hitch de temps en temps ça c'est une
bonne nouvelle je vous embrasse prenez
soin de vous et à très bientôt et bisous
Ciao
[Musique]